Speaker 1: The New York Times is now reporting
out of Brussels, the center of the euro, the
head of the European Union, Americans, American
tourists who have been fully vaccinated against
the coronavirus will be able to visit the
EU over the summer.
We don't know when that will start, but this
is based on the head of the EU in an interview
with The New York Times yesterday.
It's been more than a year since nonessential
travel for most countries has been shut down
to Europe.
And the EU is saying that because the United
States is vaccinating so quickly and because
talks have been advancing about how can we
accept vaccination certificates as proof of
immunity, the EU and the EU Commission believe
that at some point during the summer now summer
is technically, you know, it starts June 21st.
They will be able to switch policy to one
that would restore the ability of Americans
to go to Europe.
Ursula von der Leyen, president of the E.U.,
says, quote, The Americans, as far as I can
see, use European medicines, agencies, approved
vaccines.
This will enable free movement and travel
to the European Union because one thing is
clear, all 27 member states will accept unconditionally
all those who are vaccinated with vaccines
approved by the M.A, adding that the vaccines
being used here, Moderna, Pfizer and JMJ are
approved and and considered valid in the European
Union.
No current timeline, but this is sort of a
top level statement.
That guidance will be coming soon and it is
looking like we will be at 70 percent of adults
being vaccinated sometime in the month of
June.
It will all be subject to the epidemiological
situation, but that it is improving in the
US and we are starting to see an improvement
slightly in the European Union.
Now, there are already some European countries
where you can go, you can go vaccinated to
Estonia, you can go vaccinated to Iceland,
you can go to Croatia.
There are some other Eastern European countries
where you can go, but it's relatively complicated.
I have friends that have done it vaccinated,
and this seems to be a much broader discussion.
The the guess is that this will include some
kind of reciprocity as well, where presuming
that the numbers improve in Europe, the United
States will begin to do the same now.
Very important.
We are also anticipating new mask guidance
tomorrow from Joe Biden via the CDC regarding
outdoor masking.
Now, Dr. Fauci has been teasing this for some
time.
A number of different doctors, including Dr.
A Sheesha or JHA and others, have been saying,
you know, the language they've been using
has been relatively restrained, including
that it may not be a high point of contagion
outdoors.
From what we believe before there was any
vaccination, Dr. Asheesh says about one out
of a thousand cases were being transmitted
outdoors.
And you have to believe that that one out
of a thousand was not someone jogging by someone
else.
It was people doing things outdoors that are
obviously things you shouldn't be doing in
the middle of a pandemic before there are
any vaccines.
But the point is that Dr. Asheesh has been
making that psychologically.
If we can all say, hey, you know what, outside,
if you're not in a big crowd of people just
normal outside walking by, others on the sidewalk,
biking by someone, whatever, people aren't
getting sick that way.
And particularly now as we approach the.
Eighty percent vaccinated, we can ease up
on the outdoor masking, that is the expectation
for what the CDC will tell Joe Biden and Joe
Biden will announce tomorrow.
Now, it's unclear whether Joe Biden will say
only as it applies to vaccinated people.
Then you start getting into this two tiered
thing of saying if you're vaccinated, take
your mask off outside.
If you're not, don't I think that there are
some potential social issues with doing that.
But needless to say, I think that there will
be a big psychological benefit and possibly
more encouragement for people to get vaccines
if indeed the announcement tomorrow is outdoor
masking is not required other than in really
specific situations.
A mass of people at a concert, which there
shouldn't be concerts going on anyway.
A mass of people may be entering a stadium
where in the stadium with reduced capacity,
people are spread out.
But you might be funneled through metal detectors,
for example, and crowded together, even though
it's outside.
OK, where masks then.
But your typical bike path, whatever.
And have to be clear, I've been doing it all
along.
I go out on my bike, I go out running, I put
a mask on.
I do it because I'm a team player.
I don't want to be the guy being glared at.
And also there's some degree to which, you
know, if you're told to wear a mask outside
and you don't, people assume you're probably
also not wearing one inside or whatever.
So I've been wearing it.
But if indeed one when we get that announcement,
not really.
If it's more a question of when I am not going
to be wearing a mask outside.
Once the CDC says it is not necessary, it
is believed that that will be tomorrow.
And my hope is that will be another boost
to people wanting vaccines.
The CDC already saying vaccinated people can
travel without significant notable risk material
risk.
That was a great thing that made more people
say, oh, OK, that is a that's a that's a change.
I will go and get vaccinated.
And hopefully an update to mask policy tomorrow
will do the same.
So some signs, some signs that are good signs.
Some states now are down in terms of daily
deaths to close to what you see from flu.
Massachusetts as an example of recently, about
10 covid deaths a day during the average flu
season.
Massachusetts sees four flu deaths a day.
So we are getting down to, by virtue of vaccination,
a situation where it is going to be a flu
like situation.
And that changes circumstances dramatically
from when 200 people a day were dying, for
example, in Massachusetts.
So I believe there are good things coming,
but we have to keep vaccinating, is the message.
Let me know your thoughts on all of this timeline,
your behavior, your vaccination status.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
The David Pakman Show does depend on the support
of viewers and listeners like you, you can
grab a membership at join Pakman dot com,
I promise it's really easy and painless.
Check it out.
You might remember that back in twenty seventeen,
Hurricane Maria ravaged Puerto Rico, the island
of American citizens that is southeast of
Florida.
We learned at the time that many Republicans
didn't know that Puerto Ricans are American
citizens.
We also knew at the time that Donald Trump
didn't really seem to care very much about
it.
The administration was slow to send the aid
that they did send.
And we know that when Donald Trump went, he
didn't really seem to be taking it super seriously.
Remember when he showed up and tossed paper
towels into the crowd like he was shooting
hoops, were playing that video now for our
television and online video audience.
But now we have to think it wasn't merely
indifference to Puerto Rico from the Trump
administration in twenty, seventeen and twenty
eighteen, that it was actually much worse
because of a new report from the Department
of HUD Housing and Urban Development.
The inspector general of the Department of
HUD has issued a report that says that because
of tension between Department of HUD and the
Office of Management and Budget under Trump,
all sorts of bogus procedural hurdles were
put in place to delay Puerto Rico actually
getting the money.
Now, some of you will listen to me say this
and you'll go up and you'll look at money
approved for Puerto Rico and you will say,
hold, hold, hold.
Hold on a second, David.
The money was approved, 20 billion was approved
for Puerto Rico.
And Trump announced it and talked about it.
And of course, yes, the money was approved.
But the whole point is approving funds doesn't
disperse the funds.
They are separately processed.
And the Office of Management and Budget, which
would approve the distribution of the funds
around that time, started to require HUD to
send grant notices for disaster funds through
an interagency review process for approval
which never before had been required, which
dramatically slowed everything down.
Investigators found that OMB never required
such a review for recovery funds before, and
it was a requirement created in this particular
situation.
Former HUD secretary Ben Carson would be a
perfect guy to ask about all of this.
He declined to be interviewed by investigators.
Access to HUD information was delayed or denied
multiple times throughout the course of the
investigation.
And the Trump administration's OMB also insisted
on completely overhauling Puerto Rico's property
management records, suspension of its minimum
wage on federal contracts and a whole other
bunch of prerequisites.
Imagine saying we're approving 20 billion
for you, but to get it, you have to remove
the minimum wage provision on federal contracts.
What?
And some HUD officials realistically and rightly
worried that the requirements were no one
designed to make it impossible for the money
to actually be distributed and even potentially
beyond HUD's ability to actually do two top
HUD officials admitted, knowing that they
were on purpose, missing the deadline to issue
a notice that would unlock billions in federal
recovery funds to Puerto Rico.
They're not even denying it or I mean, they
didn't at the time.
Ben Carson later defended his agency's actions
by saying Trump's talking points, which are,
oh, there were we wanted to prevent corruption
and irregularities.
That's why we needed to do this stuff.
Then Ben Carson refused to actually be interviewed
by investigators here.
So now that we have a bigger picture, not
only did the Trump administration allegedly
block the much needed aid from getting to
Puerto Rico, they also obstructed an investigation
looking into why Puerto Rico didn't ultimately
get the money.
And there's nothing surprising here whatsoever
last week or the week before.
It's hard to keep track of all the scandals.
We were talking about another newly uncovered
Trump administration scam.
And I said it's not clear we will ever know
the full scope of the grift or the scamming
that this administration did.
Every time we do learn about something new
like this, my reaction is, of course, stated
that.
If you look at the public disdain that Trump
had for Puerto Rico and you look at the public
indifference that Trump exhibited, none of
these revelations is remotely surprising or
hard to believe.
And then, of course, I mean, you know, we
can't really come full circle on the implications
of this without mentioning that no matter
what comes to light, a huge portion of the
75 million people who voted for Donald Trump
in 2020 would take him right back for another
four years.
They would gleefully vote him back in if he
runs in twenty, twenty four.
And as we will talk about a little bit later
on in the program, the vast majority of them
still believe that Joe Biden did not legitimately
win the 2020 election.
But there is no news story.
There is no grift or scam or revelation that
would change their minds.
And that's a major problem for the country.
These revelations show the complicit nature
not complicit, the the the responsibility
of the Trump administration in Puerto Rico
being a disaster for as long as it was after
the hurricane.
But as much of a problem as that is, we also
have a an ongoing problem in that the vast
majority of the 75 million people that voted
for the guy would vote for him again.
And we're going to talk about that poll a
little bit later today.